مرة أخرى، المشاهد الدرامية حول
جسر كيرتش هي في الواقع مجرد
رابط مستقل يمتد من البر الرئيسي الروسي
إلى شبه جزيرة القرم المحتلة من
أوكرانيا والتي ضمتها روسيا في عام
2014. لقد رأينا هجمات سابقة على
ذلك تسبب أضرارًا، ومن غير الواضح ما إذا كانت
أدت مشاهد اليوم إلى إلحاق أضرار
بالجسر، بالتأكيد قال المسؤولون الروس إن
ذلك لم يحدث، وأن صاروخين، أحدهما
قالوا إنه صاروخ مضاد للطائرات من طراز S-200،
تم اعتراضهما في الواقع،
ثم قام المصطافون
على الشاطئ بتصوير المشاهد غير العادية
كان بدلاً من ذلك ستارًا من الدخان
مصممًا لإخفاء أي
ضربة في حالة حدوثها أو جعل من الصعب
على الصاروخ التأثير على الجسر
نفسه، ولكنه مرة أخرى تذكير للروس
بكيفية الأشياء التي ربما اعتبروها
منيعة في بداية
الحرب.  من الواضح أن الحرب أصبحت الآن في
متناول أوكرانيا، فقد شهدنا مؤخرًا هجمات بطائرات بدون طيار أوكرانية
في الجزء الشرقي من البحر الأسود، ويبدو
أنها انتصرت على
جسر كيرتش نفسه أيضًا، ولذا فإن
هجوم اليوم هو تذكير آخر بأنه إذا
وجدت أوكرانيا خطًا
مضادًا للجنوب،  يتحرك الهجوم
بوتيرة أبطأ مما قد يرغب فيه، ويبدو أنه لا يزال قادرًا
على ضرب أجزاء رئيسية من
البنية التحتية الروسية، حتى لو
لم يكن هجوم اليوم ناجحًا، فنحن
أيضًا نسمع أيضًا عن أمر أوكراني بإخلاء
مدينة تُعرف باسم كوبيانز.  بعيدًا
عن هاركي إذا كانوا يقولون إن
12000 مدني عادوا إلى
هناك منذ تحريرها من
الروس العام الماضي يجب عليهم
الإخلاء، والآن صدر أمر أكثر مباشرة
للأطفال هناك ربما أكثر من 500
ليتم إخراجهم على الفور  ويرجع ذلك
إلى الدفع الروسي هناك
بقصف مدفعي مكثف على ما تبقى من
تلك المدينة، وإشارة إلى أن موسكو ربما
تحاول تغيير السرد بعد أن
شعرت بضغط شديد في الجنوب للعثور على
منطقة أخرى ربما تصرف فيها
القوات الأوكرانية وتجبرها
على الاستسلام.  قم بتعديل مكان قوتهم
بالضرورة ولكن لا تزال المشاهد
مرة أخرى على ذلك الجسر المؤدي إلى شبه جزيرة القرم بمثابة
تذكير بأنه على الرغم من أن هجوم المقاطعة هذا
يتحرك بوتيرة أبطأ
مما ترغب أوكرانيا في أنه قادر
على إظهار القوة في مكان آخر، نيك
بيتون والش، CNN the nepro أوكرانيا